هذه لحظة تتغير فيها المنطقة
ديناميكيًا ، يمكنك أن ترى أنه
في العلاقة بين الإمارات العربية المتحدة
وإسرائيل العلاقة بين
إسرائيل والأردن ، فإن العلاقة بين
إسرائيل والعديد من جيرانها الآخرين
من المهم أن يستمر
هذا أه هؤلاء كل هؤلاء
تكون العلاقات قوة من أجل السلام من
أجل الاستقرار من أجل الازدهار ومن
المهم ألا
يترك الفلسطينيون وراءهم في تلك القصة ، لذا فمن الذي
ستضغط
عليه بشدة ، لا يتعلق الأمر بالضغط ، إنه يتعلق
بالحديث ، هذا ما يفعله الدبلوماسيون ،
هذا ما يفعله الدبلوماسيون ولكن
عندما  يأتي إلى إسرائيل
وفلسطين وهو مؤشر إلى حد ما على
دور أمريكا في المنطقة الأوسع ،
هناك نوع من الإحساس على جانبي هذا
النقاش بأن أمريكا الأخ الأكبر الذي
كان دائمًا لديه ذراع حول هذه
القضية ينسحب ،
بالتأكيد أنت تسمع هذا  كثيرًا في
هذه المنطقة ، يُنظر إلى الولايات المتحدة بشكل متزايد على
أنها شريك غير موثوق به ،
لذا إذا كان هذا هو الحال فما
هي النتيجة  يشجع
جيدًا من المنظور الأمريكي جزءًا
من سبب وجود الوزير الجديد هنا جيدًا ،
لدينا مسؤول خزانة سيأتي
الأسبوع المقبل لمحاولة تشجيع الإماراتيين على
وجه الخصوص على
عدم القيام بالكثير من الأعمال أو أي
عمل مع إيران في الوقت الذي
يكونون فيه  في محاولة للضغط على
الإيرانيين للعودة إلى
الاتفاق النووي ، وهذا هو نوع
السلوك القياسي الذي نراه
في المنطقة على الرغم من أنه لا سيما
من الإمارات ولكن أيضًا من المملكة العربية السعودية
وغيرها ، فهو شعور أكثر استقلالية بكثير.
أنهم يجب أن يكونوا
مسيطرين على مصيرهم ، لذلك
رأينا الإماراتيين يسخنون العلاقات مع
أردوغان ، لقد رأينا الإماراتيين يذهبون إلى تحسين
العلاقات مع نظام الأسد في سوريا ،
رأينا مجلس التعاون الخليجي يعيد قطر
من جديد.  البرد ، فهذه دول
تنضج في سياستها الخارجية الخاصة
بدلاً من الاعتماد على التوجيه أو مجرد
التخلف عن كل
ما تبتكره واشنطن ، وأعتقد
أن هذا سيكون في غاية الأهمية
تطور مأساوي يمثل تحديا
كبيرا للأمريكيين على مدى العقود القادمة